how's it going brahs oh that I'm saying
my name is Peter back hello penny
and now mrs. Sharon let's just go let's
just go and ignore everything it's just
you mean Betty all right I got stuck in
the last episode finally people who are
upset there was something about a
bookshelf and everyone was like I
thought the how you can miss that then
yeah here it is
I missed that I'm sorry I have feelings
too you know ah this looks creepy mr.
chair Peter yeah I'm not gonna be on it
I mean I'm gonna be on it I don't want
to go there please don't take me with
you
oh god you're taking what with you
please Thanks I do anything oh god I was
scared okay it's fine it's you me buddy
this reminds me of good times get
danceBlue these oh you see that candle
Adelita
I do that alright please sweet Petey the
[ __ ] man let's [ __ ]
is there something here I can't see
anything is so [ __ ] dark mr. chair
mr. chair ah this way beating all right
let's go mrs. cow Wow what's going on
here it's comforting go
Jan walk all right many [ __ ] are we oh
oh
bro bro I don't like that brah Rock okay
Oh save it
please there's something okay sergeant
good we're good get this Nick my rigs
now I'm all right oh wow
okay yep we got it I forgot to follow
that but whatever all right what is this
what is what is the else who's sleeping
in my bed you sleeping in my bed rock
we're doing here all right I don't like
something I want
ayuh and I need it bad give me my own I
just is stupid okay okay probably find a
lot of people in it whatever spider webs
scared me we can't gotta go into
everything scouts me oh wait I got it
found a key you're like oh what I'm
gonna do and I'm like I know you thought
it was kind of like playing some [ __ ]
and I'm like no Southwest I don't even
know where West's I don't even know how
to stop it
please move mr. Sherr I got just after
dude all right
Oh other gang banging now Oh bro
I don't like that I'm not into flying
Jesus good good just stepping on you
Oh barrels they're looking at me like
[Applause]
all right fine I have the Southwest key
so you can [ __ ] yourself barrels barrels
I hate barrels so Oh fire nice beautiful
okay focus focus focus all right we got
the fire I mean wait Southwest no no no
that's wrong that's shoulder run
Southwest all right so this is where I'm
going sound wait no it's not there
where was it what is it dad I don't
understand what it's not the guy who
left you here what look
don't you dare come alive or something
oh come on brah brah brah
maybe see here yes yes okay I got this
no problem happening I'm sure
now can go there alright get Alan what
like I can't move oh well go in here bro
I got stop know that it's so like oh oh
I was going on don't
[Applause]
that was an excellent customer I wish it
was longer honestly there's so much fun
playing it I'm sorry if this episode was
kind of sure what you gonna do I didn't
know it's gonna be short
yes I did at least I finished a custom
one I always end them like great job
dark wolf alright that was pretty much
it hope you enjoyed him though it's kind
of short I probably do something extra
for us tonight
yes pretty much it
[Music]
[Music]
ah Jesus Christ
this game has so many puzzles